the Chobe River in northern Botswana
forms the country's natural border with
Namibia while fishing and agriculture
dominate on the Namibian side Botswana
has put its side of the river under
protection that was 50 years ago and
made chobe Botswana's first national
park early morning is perfect for
watching wildlife
the mad light on the sky beautiful
70,000 jobs in Botswana depend on the
tourists who visit the country's
wildlife reserves but forego be much it
easy working as a park ranger is much
more than just a way to earn money the
national pike together with the animals
means everything it means everything to
vote on others tourism so conservation
is the most important thing we have to
love our animals we have to protect the
environment and I'm happy to be one of
those people that do that
in our country the high-pitched whine of
an electric motor this game viewer is
one of the first electric safari
vehicles on the African continent
and besides e-cars chobe game lodge also
boasts a fleet of silent solar-powered
boats and besides that it's also managed
to cut down on 95% of its waste and
garbage running ecotourism and focusing
on it is going to be paramount your
traveler these days are becoming also
more responsible and they would like to
to make sure that that if they do go on
holiday that they do support sustainable
holiday destinations
and operators with two million visitors
every year
Botswana's tourist industry ranked
second after diamond mining
conservationists around the world
command its complete ban on hunting and
fierce stance against poaching across
africa hunting and the growing human
population are forcing wildlife out of
their natural habitats many of the most
fabled species have been driven to the
brink of extinction conservationist
Robert Sutcliffe who collaborates with
the Chobe game lodge is worried even in
Botswana road construction poses a
serious threat to wildlife
one of the main reasons is habitat loss
other development throughout Africa a
lot of areas being locked for forward
and areas being cleared for farming and
then development like we're seeing in
khazzani that are pushing these animals
out of the areas that they normally
inhabit in 2012 chobe river and its
national park became the center of the
calving go Zambezi transform Tia
Conservation Area this is the home of
one quarter of the global population of
endangered African Wild Dogs
it's Africa's largest reserve and spans
five countries the aim to enable animals
to migrate naturally and freely the
effort is paid off while giraffe numbers
are dwindling in other parts of Africa
here they're still numerous that it's so
important that we work to try to
conserve the indus population that this
could be a stronghold for for giraffe
and it's also amazing to see them moving
into zimbabwe moving back into botswana
and there is no barrier to that to their
movements there which is wonderful to
see you at roughly five percent of gdp
ecotourism is still in its early stages
in botswana
but the sector is growing fast providing
a steadily increasing contribution to
the well-being of the country and its
people